what's your name Nathaniel Sexton oh did
they have sex sir I have no idea how
they got you
[Music]
all right so this is
one of my favorite videos of 2020. if
there's a bear in it I'm deleting it no
no no there's no bear why don't you like
Bears dude but there may be a bear later
on today but we'll find out it could be
a surprise
swim in a pool maybe what if this was
all just bears
just embarrassing me
all different color Bears Brown Bear
Grizzly polar bear
sun bear so a guy shows up to court this
is a zoom Court meeting okay are they
still doing that's so [__] boring
funny dude this is a great trial great
great Zoom meeting I love these things
[Music]
three thousand
Nathaniel Saxon sir
their name's not butt [__] 3000
log into my court with that the lady in
the bottom left
um
idiot logs into court like that
what's your name again
Nathaniel section sir but I don't
believe that
I typed anything like that
I am
waiting you shut up limbo for a while
[Laughter]
butt [__] 3 000. why did you know he
didn't know
why did he write that okay
what's your name Nathaniel Saxton
[Applause]
[Laughter]
like it sounds like an infomercial
product
he's like the future of butt [__]
hahaha
I love those situations where like a
buddy messes with your computer or some
[__] and then you go try to do something
serious it's like his high school son oh
God [__] 3 000. yeah
he had that voice though where it's like
I have no clue how that got there what
me I believe him yeah I believe you
believe him
what do you think what do you think he's
going to court for he's going to court
for [__] cheating on his wife by like
[__] some other dude in the butt so
she's the one who logged in for him oh
it's like a vindictive uh like wife
crime
that's so funny that's [__] epic dude
that's honestly when you pulled up the
zoom meetings I thought we're gonna see
a guy jerk off or something yeah that's
what I thought like someone's balls
thank you I can't think of a better name
that's the norm dude that is the norm
like they didn't guy do that during
covet like there was a meeting Jeffrey
Tubidy he thought that yeah he exited
and he just pulled out his [__]
started jerking it Jeffrey tubing CNN
CNN guy and he just starts whacking he
just starts beating it and beating it
he's like barely off the zoom call too
and he's like right away right out yeah
and everybody's trying to [__] like
tell him you did it or some [__] dude
when technology means [__] dinosaurs
bro but he was like he's taking it out
like there's a guy in the room with a
gun who's like take your [__] out you
better come right now
and then he had to continue yeah that
could be probably I mean he was on his
mind I mean he grabbed like the [__]
Kleenex and the lotion it was like the
full setup you know he wasn't messing
the full regalia you gotta get those
nuts off maybe you get really stressed
out on on Zoom you're all stressed
during coven man yeah you can't even fit
an ad between when the zoom ended and
the jacking started like it was so fast
maybe he had another Zoom meeting like
in 10 minutes and his buddy just sent
him a new link oh he's like hey check
just check this up there's always an
explanation that's totally practical oh
[__] dude so yeah this is basically
over um this is over a a drug
paraphernal charge
um during a traffic stop cops found a
syringe with meth in it meth residue
um in the guy's truck and he agreed to
pay fine 200
um and yet he said that he was uh the
judge said that he was lucky to have
escaped the day's events without making
attempt of Court charge for his screen
name [__] 3000 really imagine that
on your permit record like when you try
to get a job
he's kind of but he's kind of becoming a
minor celebrity online because this
video is so [__] funny it's so funny
yeah I wonder what his next [__]
bit's gonna be you know [__] too
now he's now he won't be able to resist
he triples up dude that's his name now
but [__] 3 000. he's gonna do ad reads
for [__] dildos
this judge by the way he like likes to
broadcast a lot of his um Court
proceedings like which include like some
of the people's like worst moments like
this moment right so that's why we're
seeing this God the judge likes to
broadcast he likes to do the best moment
it's like that one Florida judge that
female who's like always posting all of
the clips of every one of her trials
have you ever seen those no oh she and
like she ran into her old uh oh that one
yeah she ran into her old classmate when
she was in grade school oh that one yeah
yeah she always puts her stuff up it's
pretty interesting when some judges want
to do that what did she do with the
great school she was like um
like this dude was on trial for
something and then she's like hey like I
remember you like remember Miss
something's class back and he just
started sobbing wow it's like really
powerful I remember that yeah is it
because they were like they were
classmates together yeah she goes like
whatever I was wondering whatever
happened to you you're so good you were
such a good kid and he just started like
bawling it's like rough
she's like you're such a good lady
you're so good to me and my [__]
and then he starts crying he's like he's
choked up oh my [__] is so good
where did I go wrong he falls through
his knees dude how did these Zoom Court
things
have you ever done anything like this do
judges need content baby but like okay I
didn't know they were still doing to go
to court like that that's so strange to
me yeah why
don't show up anyway I mean they're
still they're still like [__] covet
or whatever new variants so like maybe
if uh you know somebody gets sick it's
like okay we just have to do this one
online because it's available or maybe
they just found out that like this is
just way easier to do I guess it is
possible that's true because you wait
you wait less time too yeah maybe you
could get more cases in during the day
dude go into jury duty even like knowing
that you have to do that is like insane
dude [__] jury duty Bro [__] jury duty
I'm out but they give you a sandwich in
like 40 bucks yeah right they use 15 and
then maybe serving your civic duty
you're sitting there for like nine hours
doing nothing but you don't like being
American I do but not not for jury duty
have you guys all done jury duty yeah
I've never done Drake I've never done
jury duty is unfair though man because
like depending on what district you're
from you could get a bad case yeah like
remember I was telling you guys like
like because my my [__] districts
Compton courthouse
all my cases are like [__] 18 Crips
looking at me they know my name I'm the
one deciding the fate of their best
friend and you were like the leader of
like that's not fair other places you
were the foreman yeah it was a
four-person yeah of course other places
are gonna get like oh Financial
embezzlement yeah like I'll take that
[__] in Irvine dang that's crazy it's
super unfortunate you're a wild you have
to park in the same lot as everybody
who's going to watch the case by the way
yeah so they know your license plate
they know your car it's like they just
follow you home it's super you acquitted
the guy huh you're like [__] this yeah
for your own personal safety you quit
the guy you're crazy you're like not
guilty not guilty I actually talked
about the case in detail when we went to
Vegas and then afterwards I was like
actually can we take that out
[__] these guys might be looking for me
man yeah that's the reason why judges
get ccw's like they can have a concealed
carry already because they deal with
crazy ass [__] but then the
jury does that I get to have one no we
don't get [__] but how sick if every
judge's robe just Chandelier
[Laughter]
dramatic that's trench coat [__] yeah
jury duty it definitely like is is very
based on like where your district is it
sucks man I served technically but I
wasn't chosen yeah I sure but I wasn't
joking because I was sitting there or
alternate does that mean they already
chose the the the jury so they dismissed
the rest of us so I served
as you show up you did your duty I did
that once well now that that part's on
the that's not even a remember before
back in the day you had to go in and sit
there all day to not be chosen now you
don't have to do that if you're just not
chosen the first date you'll just you
just have to check on the phone and then
you also like go up to the judge and
tell them why you can't do it because
you're like I'm racist that never that
doesn't work anymore I don't speak
English that that might work
laughs